[Music]
well we can't encourage it enough if you
are out able
and eligible please get vaccinated
tonight a message
from those on the front lines who are
facing even more challenges
when it comes to coving here's orcomano
with the story
it was just a lot of suspense a lot of
worry you know you think of the worst
for las vegas reynaldo herrera the past
several weeks have been filled with fear
he says he almost lost his close friend
hugo to the coronavirus
he got covered about two months ago he
just got off the life support
about two weeks about two three weeks
ago it is a miracle that he's alive
this story is not unique
hospitalizations continue to climb
across the country due in large part to
the delta variant
and doctors across the valley are
feeling the strain
there are days then that we are really
you know on the word dr vika sayal
says his pulmonology facility is at
around 90 percent capacity
right now and they're seeing more covert
patients now than this time last year
we are very overwhelmed we have multiple
people in the er uh waiting to get a bet
in their
intermediate care we have seen people in
their
40s and 50s that have
passed because of covid dr sayal says
because of the influx he's also noticing
more health care workers contracting the
virus
some of them have gotten very sick to
the point
that they needed icu care his main
message
please get yourself vaccinated herrera
agrees especially after what his friend
went through
him being in that situation uh
you know materialized or catalyzed me
going to get that vaccination about
three weeks ago so i got my second shot
yesterday
orco mana 8 news now